talking about women and love that we
have for women and you know our brother
Habib recently he was asked by a woman
and it seemed like it was setup you know
it was like Saudi Arabia yeah so so the
woman came and she asked them
[Music]
all the time finish
Oh what advice would you give yes yes
yeah what advice would you give for
someone new woman who wants to get in
the cage and I go back I said fight in
the house yeah yeah he says smash your
husband right he's he's a smash your
husband but then he got a lot of and
people were asking me you know on the
front page news it was front page was it
yeah one of the right-wing newspapers we
have what's called Daily Mail you're
kidding me yeah they put him on there
most of it was a front page I don't
think it was but it was a feature so I
was thinking about this I said hold on I
mean we're coming he's coming from it
from an angle of love I mean loving you
know really honoring the woman and
everybody who's there is actually
nobody's booing and it's a different
culture but how can you go ahead and
implement now because if you're a Jew if
you're a Christian if you're someone who
now wants to be at the highest level of
morality or religion you believe in God
there they're gonna be on this side so
how do you I mean how would you answer
this when you come down to it
how could you impose your cultural you
know your worldview on a whole nation
and start to put him down because we
believe he's honored I think that we
would have more evidence and proven from
you know something that's not so
subjective that's objective that you
know to substantiate what he's saying
that's even more beneficial absolutely
I mean think of it this way imagine if
it was the opposite way around uh-huh
imagine if a man came up and he asked
the same question right uh-huh and he
said what can I do and what want to you
know be a fire UFC fighter and he said
to him I give you advice to to fight
home uh-huh would it would it bring half
as much controversy as it did or if it
was a woman telling a man that it
wouldn't bring any controversy
whatsoever and the reason why is because
there is no controversy attached to
doing things like raising your children
the only controversy that's attached to
that is that which the second or third
wave feminists have put on it but really
and truly what makes what working in a
career you know working for a man
usually is anyways for a woman any more
beneficial for that woman than raising
her own children who will grow to love
her I mean the truth is when that woman
is working in let's say we have it in a
city like or sum or corporation
organization the the man who's usually
in charge of that
position of power can say to a you know
go away you're fired mm-hmm obviously
there are employment rights and all that
kind of thing in place but that's still
a possibility and she's still working
for a man so whether she's fighting in
the corporation if fighting for her
career or she has a you know a job
elsewhere she's still gonna be doing
exerting a lot of effort so I don't
think there was that much controversy or
that there is that much controversy in
in that he's just saying that he doesn't
see UFC as a good option for a woman I
would put to him that I don't see UFC as
a good option for a man either to be
honest with you yeah because it's from
our Islamic perspective you know there's
a lot that goes wrong with it I mean you
have cash flower art like you know you
have to show which to be fair khabib
does as well which is which is wrong
which he shows his thigh part of his leg
there's there's also the ring girls that
have to come in explain that to me
I mean how does that fit in the equation
I mean so what I'm saying is that if we
want to be honest with you girls about
you like we were talking about UFC or
any other promotion then we have to be
completely honest and we have to say
okay well actually it's not is it
to what extent is it a gender issue
because why would it be Haram it would
be harmful you have cash flower art you
have the hour of being shown he does
that himself he should he could fix that
problem by just covering his time
absolutely yes yes the wrinkles he cut
is not really too much in control of
that but it's something we cannot
endorse that you have a woman there
being objectified holding a card you
know totally objectified I mean look at
that totally wrong you have issues to do
with the promotion itself where it's a
lot about ego and that's completely
against Islam and a dollar which is
another issue with praying mass harm to
somebody and if you're doing the on a
regular basis I mean I wouldn't tell my
son to be a UFC fighter because my
because then I know or even a boxer
because I know that that can have a
long-term effect on their mental
faculties whereas a grapplers or BJJ
practitioner yeah they might have some
joint pain etc but it might not be to
the extent whereby their mental
faculties are how proper have a problem
like that so we're talking about health
anyway
so the issue of the woman is obviously
she's showing more power that's the main
issue that's the main difference she's
gonna be showing more of her hour off
from an Islamic perspective there's more
for a woman to govern in there is for a
man that's the main issue apart from
that I mean the rulings that we just
talked about pretty universal and
consistent so to be honest and fair we
have to kind of look at what could be
said and and kind of analyze it from its
lamp perspective and say well I mean
your right to an extent but you also you
know you're not being completely honest
to an extent as well because the UFC and
all these promotions and boxing
promotions they do things that for a man
a harem to do not just for all men so if
we're being honest we would say it like
that but the point on a woman being
scrutinized because she's she's raising
her children I mean the alternative
being that she should be pumping money
for the economy that a man's gonna take
him put into his pocket anyways it's
quite ironic I would say so I don't I
don't buy the either when you look at it
I mean what you said objectified at the
end of the day with the ring girls is a
sport why do you have women in g-string
walking around I mean you know for any
any woman to think and to look I mean
and the honor that the Creator has given
the woman right and they just have for
instance any man even if he's not
let's say a person whose religious
usually back in Jogja Leah yeah the man
has you know the beautiful woman and
he's showcasing her around he's happy to
see it that's his trophy but after he
developed some some some feelings for
her you know the natural thing comes in
like cover up now he's like before she
headed up to the knee up to the thigh
and he's like look at my girl and then
and now he's like he's telling her like
put more on right you know that that
Lita that natural jealousy comes in yes
and but who would want their their
beloved their wife you know to be
showcasing but what I'm in doing now
there what why what are men when they're
looking at these women out there
what would see focus on old nice harbor
or where's his mind that he wears his
mind that's your wife now yeah 100% and
you know at this point over here are we
were gonna do a video that with
actually about because we're latest how
would you how would you try to protect
the jealousy absolutely yeah so Lila is
best translated into protective jealousy
and it can be from man to woman or
mentor a man theorems but it's usually
used in the context of protective
jealousy in the context of a man
protecting womenfolk and it's this idea
of masculinity which i think is becoming
more popular nowadays with the influence
of jordan pearson and other people like
that because the the false divide that
they've made now or the false notion
that okay there is no such thing as
masculinity it's all a social construct
this is the popular notion of the second
and third wave feminists say look
there's no such thing as masculinity
masculine is a social construct
therefore you know we should ignore
these notions of masculinity and
femininity and go back to a Universalist
kind of approach obviously from an
Islamic perspective we reject this
entirely wholeheartedly reject us
because we have we believe that
different things should be treated
differently same thing can be treated
the same but different things should be
it's a simple thesis yeah so it's
different things are treated differently
and men and women have to have
differences then in cases of those
differences there should be a different
prescription and so for example we were
talking about martial arts and there's
no doubt I don't even think the biggest
feminists in the world would would argue
the fact that men are stronger than
women why don't they put this why don't
they they have the same weight classes
put her to fight the man in the same
weight classes so I actually saw some
some things being said recently about
this right and you know what it's a
really good question you're asking that
question you know because this links
into the transgender debate and you know
I found something really interesting and
you can find it on YouTube yeah one of
the one of the biggest feminists who's
ever lived in the 21st century who's
still alive
her name is Germaine Greer mmm-hmm she's
written a book called the Female Eunuch
yeah in 1971 she wrote that book and
it's a very very famous book the woman
is still alive and you'll see if you go
online if you check her name you'll see
a clip of her talking about transgender
people and feminists have grappled okay
not to use any puns here but they've
grappled over this point right what to
do with transgender people
she's a hard advocate of the fact that
someone who trans who who does the
operation and becomes from X Y to X X
first of all that'sthat's not a
legitimate thing so she would say that
it's not really she's that person is not
becoming a man now
well that person is not becoming a woman
now they're still they should be
identified with their previous
biological identification and as an
extension of the argument someone would
argue if a woman for example let's say
you have a big Alistair Overeem or
Thomas or khabib uh-huh I mean obviously
we're not maybe not use the cabbie
let's use as the ovaries huge yeah right
say honey way yeah if he Trey if he does
the operation and well maybe not him
because I don't think they have that way
carrion bats
Bob Sapp you heard a Gary Goodridge no
go back he accepted Islam just and just
like that yeah he's a legend but go
ahead keep going let's say he looks like
Bob Salvin was like Floyd Mayweather
okay he doesn't he doesn't operation and
he now becomes over you know he
identifies himself as a woman he
automatically as soon as he does that is
there gonna be a fair competition
between him and any other female boxer
absolutely not
and and you know the feminists will be
the first one people like Jimmy and
Greer be the first ones to come out and
say no this is not fair how can someone
who has the interest the the mechanical
infrastructure of a man has had to
suffer and for all of their lives has a
muscular and skeletal structure which
resembles that of a man be in
competition with woman this puts women
in a disadvantageous position and so
they would reject on that basis but you
can't have your cake and eat both
because if they're making that argument
then fair enough you can make that
argument which we would all agree with
you on but you have to also say then
that that means that men have these
advantages and therefore they should
have certain different treatments women
yes and if we say that so to what extent
now do we differ the treatment between
men and women mmm-hmm and that's that's
the that's the question I we have to say
that we have to put forward because with
this we've identified there that biology
has an impact
social prescriptions and if we've
identified that then the question is all
about extent now to what extent should
biology having a difference have
something to say about social
prescriptions between the two genders
and that's why we would say as Muslims
obviously the man has certain advantages
and should complement the natural
attributes of woman with those
advantages and so for instance on this
case of Hira because this is what kind
of started off with of clara the
protective jealousy even from a
biological perspective even though we're
not evolutionist from a human
perspective they would even say from an
evolutionary biology [ __ ] but that's
what they would argue right from an
evolutionary biology perspective from
their perspective right the man is the
hunter-gatherer the man is the one who's
been you know doing these things even
from their perspective you can make a
strong argument that this is the natural
most efficient state of a man to be in
right and so for that for that reason
many others here are is something not
only needed but it's something which
comes naturally yeah you have a did they
get much heat when you have feeder
element oh the Russian fighter you had
beliefs George st. Pierre last year I
was with Horace gracie he was in the
back seat and we were riding it was
three of us and he were talking about
this issue they were all on the same
page just like
kabylia but I'm just curious if they got
this much press this much negative
feedback as he did yeah and you had and
you do have a lot of people that have
this belief also I mean they feel
strongly about this you know preserving
the woman and not putting her out there
to get I mean you're married she's
coming home you know broken you know
bones in her face and you know someone
who Yuri her protector you're supposed
to guarantee her safety you took her
from what used to be you took her from
her father and now you're gonna go ahead
and you know protect this woman yeah but
them these are great legends in a sport
they've also they've also expressed the
same thing like Habib's expressed have
you seen that they got this much
backlash that's a good point I think is
trying to they try to link it to this
narrative isn't it they try to link it
to this whole Muslim narrow
and you know that Muslims it is it is it
like fishing for anything you know yeah
if you look at the Daily Mail article I
mean it's very clear that they're
linking it as religion they're leaving
it to his his beliefs etc Daghestan all
of those things they they want to make
him out to be some alien and so
obviously and that's why the UFC doesn't
treat him with the same kind of
respective as will treat someone like
Conor McGregor yeah but what if you what
I said earlier if you're a Jew you're
Christian and you hold to Christianity
or Judaism or any of us many of these
world religions you would also I mean
what would jure be let's stick with
those two as a Jew practicing Jew or
Christian what would they say if they're
asked this you know to allow like if if
you're a Christian you and espouse to
have oh you know what exact yeah us in
the Bible
first Timothy says that the head of
every household is the man you know when
I went to a church recently there was a
debate between at nominal sheet and a
man called Samuel Greene and the people
the the woman in the church were talking
with a loud voice and the other men
there you know you have to be quiet in
the church you shouldn't even be talking
in the church wait the man said that in
yeah yeah most of this was recorded but
yeah I paint that picture so you're in
the church you're there I was in the
church and there was a woman talking
there was there was two or three women
that were raising their voices and then
who and someone told the men they were
like you know in the church the woman
can't talk over the man they said that
they I said that to their scriptures
there because that's obviously something
that says in the Bible right yeah so
yeah I mean I don't know why is this
this this is stress on Islam and Muslims
I mean go anywhere in the world forget
about Islamic Muslims forget about
religion you go to it sub-saharan Africa
gender roles are clearly defined go to
Asia most of Asia gender roles just
because post-colonial white man has
decided you know after certain time
period in his life they want to impose
these rules on human beings we have to
follow suit and become silent and all of
our traditions are meaning meaningless
now until they change their mind